talk about you and Ransom your guys's
friendship your partnership obviously
you guys have crazy chemistry together
working on a project partnering up with
KD but what is it about Ransom you guys
I feel like have each kind of had your
own interesting
route through the music industry but you
guys are both still here you guys are I
feel like each hitting your stride in a
way that like is dope to see because I
remember getting like Ransom a team [__]
like [__] my I might have been in high
school or at least like 18 or 19. you
know what I'm saying right
um but it's just dope to kind of see you
guys work together and I feel like you
guys do have similar come UPS in a way
you know
um talk about your guys's friendship and
partnership and what it is about ran
that you guys click so well uh you know
man me and ran we we we're like in a lot
of ways and [__] we really do our own
thing and we really don't play the
politic game you know like this [__] is
really based on politics a lot of it
yeah you know what I'm saying so like me
and ran we both got the same attitude
and we [__] who [__] with us
you know I'm saying we might we ain't
going to the events we're not going to
be seen we're not shaking too many hands
we really [__] with who [__] with us you
know that should hinder you in this
it'll also make you question
whether or not you're doing the right
[__] right it'll subconsciously also
influence the music if you if you
actually get too worried about
I didn't go to the rap caviar party for
the Grammys or you know all this
[__] you know what I mean right and
not not to say that that's [__]
because I've been on the rap caviar
podcast a lot you know and
uh from all of that now I'm playing
politics [__] you know I could see like
I was always a fan of ram but at the
point of time he stopped rapping and I
understood he was going through and at
that point in time I realized that it
was a way for us to monetize without
having to play the politic game yeah so
and I went and hollered at him I had one
conversation with him and
he was back active with a Vengeance he's
been on his [__] and he's been going
crazy for sure you know what I'm saying
so like since then you know we we we we
built a lot of
a lot of music you know what I'm saying
and just built a strong partnership you
know what I'm saying
what is this album sounding like that
you're working on with uh Mr Durant is
it is it uh an EP is it a full project
is it like
honestly it sounded like some real
Soulful heartfelt you know I'm saying
some real Soulful heartfelt [__] right
now we got we um we've been working with
the producer [__] oh yeah [__] is a
legend yeah Bankers gonna produce the
whole album that's crazy yeah so you
know yeah [__] is a legend yeah big is
definitely a legend that's hard yeah so
that's going to be crazy me ran and Bing
you know that's crazy you know what's
gonna happen you guys are gonna put out
this crazy body of work and now you guys
are gonna have to drop one off like once
a year for for the fans yeah we ready we
prepared for that yeah we prepared for
that so much so much in the works man
hell yeah for you was there what was the
Catalyst to make you kind of realize
that
it wasn't about all the politicking that
there was an actual road to not being on
a major label not doing things a
conventional way but yet still getting
to the money get into a career yeah
that's all it was like man once I made a
couple dollars that was it for me I was
like I all I gotta do is multiply this
whatever I did to make this amount
started with me being able to pay my
bills off of music you know that was
which is a big deal that was a huge deal
if you could support yourself on your
music you made it right here we go and
and you know it started was like oh wow
like and I would that's when I kind of
like you know changed my whole lifestyle
I said if I could pay my bills off this
I'm not gonna do if I'm doing anything
else I'm being greedy yeah you're being
greedy and you're you're and you're
jeopardizing them you know yeah so so so
that's where it started so then it was
like I if I pay my bills maybe if I work
harder maybe I could obtain a lifestyle
difference yeah if I'm doing if I'm
doing enough to get the bills paid if I
do a little bit more so you know with
that and with me making that my only
hustle that was another thing I had to
because you get all the energy in one
thing I had to put all the energy into
one thing I couldn't have no uh no plan
B see I realize like you know you get
what you plan for yeah you know so if
you if you like yo this might not work
I'm gonna have a plan B you gonna get
the plan B subconsciously yeah you
prepare for the plan for sure so you're
gonna get what you prepared for you know
what I'm saying and if you're and you're
gonna get what you what you put into it
exactly so if you're if you're putting
20 of your energy into whatever else it
might be right and you're only giving
the music stream 80 or 70 right you're
cutting yourself short right so that's
basically was my turnaround when I was
like all right let me
let me get my all to this and that's
what happens and see what happened and
each year I started you know
things start getting a little better you
know what I'm saying and that's
basically what it is when I like I said
when I made it my only source of income
I started educating myself on every way
I could make some money because that's
the only way I can make money now see
when it wasn't my only source of income
it was like all right I'm just talented
but you ain't making no money from
nowhere else right you're not gonna
leave a rock unturned you got to turn
that you like let me see what's going on
here how they did that how they did this
you become extra inquisitive and that's
that was like the whole turning point
for me when this was all I had did you
ever pay attention to there's an R B
singer um named Ryan Leslie definitely
he was doing a lot of monetizing his fan
base from the major label system I feel
like early real early yeah real early he
was on it before you know a lot of guys
was really you know he was one of the
first that was really like while he was
doing that too working on this website
quality Club I think where you could go
and like I think he was putting albums
out you could only buy from him but for
you you you see the benefit of having
the streaming platforms eventually get
it as well of course because you know
that's a whole nother source of income
and that's the game that the labels
place and that's a way for Discovery to
be higher for you of course because if
you have LeBron I'm not sure LeBron's
buying the album on PayPal checking it
out yeah right so the ones are streaming
on Apple music of course to discover you
gotta have that visibility you know what
I'm saying so like I'm not you know I'm
not opposed to dealing with the
streaming sites you know what I'm saying
just want to make sure you get as much
as you can